Hey there, friends from the future. Whether that's
the two second delay that we're on or
if you're watching this on video at some
time in the, at some time down the
road. I'd like to welcome you back to
middle Monday.
We will be looking at
high availability with BGP today,
And,
I am Jeremy Tanner,
penguin on the Internet. And, word is we'll
be talking about a different sort of bird
today.
I'd like to bring in the cohosts.
We have
Tom Crow.
Hey, gang. David McKay.
Hey. How's it going? Dan Finnerin.
Hello.
There we go. Alright. So
we are gonna try and tackle a
common
problem, I guess, that people have with scaling
on bare metal.
Anyone wanna talk about that?
Yeah. Sure. I suppose. I mean,
I one of the key
issues
that people kind of hit, I guess, within
bare metal environments is
lack of facilities
and how best to kind of
manage those and emulate things that would normally
require physical devices.
So I guess that's kind of some of
the stuff that we're gonna be covering today
in terms of
using
a few different techniques for providing high availability
of services
on bare metal.
Nice. So I believe our our plan is
we're gonna
spin up
just, I guess, some random NGINX servers across
a variety of bare metal machines. And then
our first challenge is we
we we wanna be able to provide some
load balancing across those edge and x servers.
And
then we wanna be able to remove the
single point of failure from
the load balancing by using
BGP.
Now maybe we could I'm just gonna nominate
you Dan since you're a resident expert here.
I'm not so.
Can like so I think I'm hoping you
know, the people viewing are are gonna have
a good understanding of NGINX and load balancing,
we're gonna use a J proxy for that.
These are tools that most people
probably familiar with, however,
a concern that you may not have, I
would say the bare metal environments would be
BGP and
and using that with elastic IPs etcetera. So
can you just kinda give us the quick
one or two minute overview of what that
problem is and how we solve it?
Yep. So,
I mean, the the cool kind of concept
really here is the
the virtual IP or the elastic IP in
this instance, which
in
cloud parlance, you typically will go
I require
an EIP or I require one of these
virtual IP addresses.
And you can add your services underneath it,
and magic typically will happen whenever traffic goes
to that I IP address that you asked
for.
You will be passed to one of the
instances that sits underneath it.
There is magic that is transpiring
between your virtual machines and that Elastic IP
in
a bare metal or on premises
environment,
that magic is typically
BGP.
And what BGP is doing
is saying,
you enable BGP on all of those instances,
and all of those instances are saying
to the networking equipment,
you can route to me to access
services that I'm actually running. So all of
the machines that you would have in your
your pool
will all advertise that that Elastic IP. They
will all say, I am advertising my services
from the the the address that was given.
And the routers themselves can actually take care
then of sending traffic to one of the
instances that are actually advertising that Elastic IP.
And just so we're all on the same
page, Dan, do you mind telling people what
BGP is?
So BGP
just quickly going on to Wikipedia. No. BGP
my hands are here. BGP is border
I've forgotten. Border gateway. Gateway protocol.
And it is used
throughout the Internet for
routes and machines advertising
to the rest of the Internet that if
you want to get to these particular IP
addresses,
then send your traffic through me or through
this particular device.
And I that you know, these routes that
we're advertising will get you to where you
need to go.
I suppose it's also worth mentioning the BGP
has also been notable
for some of the larger Internet outages
over the last few years
where there have been
human errors or,
in some cases,
bad actors that have,
been on on the Internet and said to
other devices on the Internet,
hey. You wanna get to Google? Then send
your traffic through me.
At which point,
you'll find that Google has disappeared off the
Internet because the traffic is going somewhere that
it isn't meant to do.
So, yeah, BGP is powerful, but also, in
the wrong hands, dangerous.
Yeah. I think since I I started this
position and I have become a lot more
familiar with BGP, I'm starting to notice just
how many of those BGP hijackings and denial
of service attacks actually happen on the the
big old Internet much more frequently than I
expected.
Yeah. It's one of the key issues really
is that BGP has been implemented for quite
some time.
But
randomly, not a lot of people have decided
to
protect
the devices or or protect how they advertise
BGP routes. So
there's been a lot of work now to
ensure that a random person can't just advertise
routes that they're not meant to be doing.
But that has been the case for quite
some time.
Alright. Cool.
So let's just get started then. Alright. We're
gonna walk through. So
yeah, we're gonna walk through using the UI
and do as many of these components as
we can interactively
but one of my homework for after today's
episode is to produce this as a Hulumi
setup inside of our Git repository. So I
will do that and should look. But for
now,
just for brevity and the focus, we're gonna
do the UI,
which is conveniently pretty good anyway.
So
let's go I guess we'll just go with
Ubuntu. Everyone happy with that? Yes,
Dave? Alright. Thanks.
And we'll do NGINX one two three.
Yeah. Why not? Let's just try and set
this up. So we'll just you can't see
that. So
There
we go. There we go. So I'll just
do this here because it should be pretty
quick anyway. So we'll do an app update
install.
Because nginx is just one of those packages
which is super simple.
Non interactive.
Have I made any mistakes? Anyone?
Yes.
Minus y for asking questions. Yep. Alright.
Done. That's it.
Now it would have been a good time
to describe what BGP is actually.
As we wait a few minutes for these
machines to come up.
I guess I could talk a little bit
about what I found confusing with BGP and
maybe that hopefully helps other people.
But when I started kinda reading up on
it and this was a matter of weeks
ago, so you know my knowledge is
very preliminary at this moment in time. Is
that I didn't actually understand that BGP had
a use case internally and locally as well
rather than just global BGP.
Like for, you know,
advertising IP addresses within a single autonomous system.
There's still a very valid use case for
doing stuff for that. And that kinda caught
me off guard and I think it caused
a lot of confusion when I was reading
up and what it was. So really interesting
protocol.
It's I suppose it's kind of interesting that
a lot of people are probably using it
without really realizing.
So for instance, if you're using Calico
as your CNI plug in for a Kubernetes
cluster,
what is typically happening there is the the
pods that you are creating,
they're given an internal IP address,
and the bird BGP protocol
is being used to advertise to all of
the nodes in the cluster that to get
to this pod IP address,
you should send your traffic
through you should route your traffic through the
host where the pod actually is now running.
So it's doing all of that. You just
it's all transparent to the end user.
Nice
to know.
I'm just gonna spin up our HEProxy machine
just now too. Oh, we want two HEProxies,
don't we?
Because we're gonna do high availability of the
HEProxy.
And then we just need one machine
with what's the program that we're gonna be
using today to do the BGP
announcements?
So the program that we'll be running on
the nodes that we want to advertise from
is called BERD,
which is the BGP
Internet routing daemon
off the top of my head. I think
I've got that right. Apologies if not.
Quite simply,
what that will do is we tell it
these are the networking device these are the
IP addresses of the networking devices in our
environment.
This is the address that we would like
to advertise that is coming from us ourselves
as server,
and it will then start advertising that to
the to the network.
Okay. So I've got my first question then.
Do we install BERD on our h a
proxy machines, or does BERD run on its
own machine away from the h a proxies
that we wanna
provide high availability for?
So
Bird is effectively
just going to do
advertising
IP address
to the outside world, we would need HAProxy
running on the same machines because we would
need the TCP ports to be advertised
from that address. So if we were if
we didn't do that,
our Elastic IP would go to a machine,
but we would have no ports to connect
to or anything like that.
Okay. Pop quiz then, hotshot. What's the BERT
package called on Ubuntu?
Birds? I I actually I'm not entirely sure.
Can
Google Google help me. I think it's just
called bird. Bird hyphen b g p. Bird
hyphen b g p. Oh, well, there's actually
a bird and a bird b g p.
It does. No. This is a traditional package.
It's okay. So I think we can get
away with just bird.
And then I think bird BGP would have
been the old name and then this was
provided
just to make it still work.
We'll find out anyway. So. Let's see what
happens. Yep. So this is our second set
of machines. We're gonna install h e proxy.
We're also gonna install bird. And it doesn't
matter if this user data fails because we're
just gonna jump on each of the machines
anyway and start
doing things manually till we get it all
working.
So let's see if this worked. Make sure
I didn't break the user data on machine
one.
I always do that.
Anyway.
Okay.
I'm gonna assume that that worked on all
the machines. We have our three engine axes.
We've got our two h a proxy machines
spitting up.
And I asked Dan what the next step
is. I'm hoping he doesn't say go on
an h a proxy machine.
The next step is to go on a
h a proxy machine.
Alright. Or we or we can take the
time for for brief correction.
The b in bird is is not for
BGP. What's it for?
It's
like new.
It's recursive.
The b stands for bird.
Bird Internet
Well, I didn't name it. That's that's insane.
Well, we invite a guest out of Jeremy.
She's laughing him down with directions already.
That's fine. It's
that's
It is just a it's a whole of
mirrors all the way down. There's a recursive
loop forever then.
Correct.
So just to ask a few questions then.
I mean, is BERT the only way to
do this kind of setup? Are there other
tooling? Is there newer tooling? Like, what is
the the status quo when it comes to
BGP here?
From the experiences that I've had, it's if
you are wanting to
do this via software running on a server
itself, then
Bird is
the kind of de facto way of doing
it.
Other software solutions that do exist so for
instance, if you are wanting to use something
like service type load balancer in a Kubernetes
cluster,
metal l b is the defacto standard
at the moment.
But
that has a a BGP server
written in Go
that runs so when you when you advertise
a service type address,
it does exactly the same sort of thing.
It will say, this is my load balance
address outside worlds.
I have I have it. Route through me
to get to the pods that sit underneath
me.
And that's its own written in Go. But
Bird is typically the one that you would
see.
I mean, one may have taken an opportunity
to talk about their own project there too.
I was gonna say, isn't it a isn't
it a challenger to the market on for
in metal l b right now?
Maybe
at some point or another.
There is there's actually been there's there's PureLB,
which is a a full commit LB that
does the same sort of thing. Okay.
CubeVip, which is one that I've been part
of, which also
implements its own native
BGP server in Go.
Trying think what else there is.
I Rust one. There has to be a
Rust one. Come on. More than likely, there
there will be a Rust one. Yeah. There'll
be Rust LB or something. Yep. Must be.
Alright. Well, we do have our HG proxy
machines.
So
let's jump on one of them.
That was pretty fast to spin up five
servers y'all.
I moved my microphone and I reached my
fingerprint reader. It's a pain in the ass.
Anyway,
let's see. Itch a proxy.
Alright. So that will work.
So let's take a look at our HAProxy
configuration.
And what we actually wanna do here is
configure our back ends to be the three
engine axes
and serve that over
probably just the same port.
So let's see if I can remember how
to write an engine x config slash pull
one up on my other screen and hope
that nobody notices I'm looking at it.
Hey, MacKay. What are looking for looking at
on your other screen?
I'm
just checking the time. I know it's early
for you. I want you to be considerate.
Oh, look. There's this magical thing I just
copy and pasted. So
we can define our front advanced.
We can define our front ends like this.
So let's grab our IP addresses.
And I should actually just let's just share
this too actually.
This is just coming from our guides and
Equinix metal docs. So there's this great guide.
I can't zoom in on the URL bar,
can I? No.
Metals.iconx.com/developers/docs/guides/loadbalancing-aj.
I'm
stealing everything from there.
Oh, okay. So IP addresses. NGINX one.
So front end.
Port 80.
Grab this one.
And number three.
And let's see. So that's defined three front
ends, which I'm not sure if it's completely
correct because I'm skimming this very quickly.
Nope. Let's do it front end one and
two.
And they provide a back end pool of
engine x which do I need to configure
anything for? Yep.
I'm doing this all wrong.
Please stand by. Okay. We'll get there. Piece
by piece. By piece. So
what we we don't wanna bang the front
end is what we're load balancing on. So
we we actually did want www.
This is gonna be our elastic IP which
we've not allocated yet.
And then this is our engine x pool
where we do render up in TCP
and we can actually use the internal IP
addresses.
Using the public ones was very naive of
me.
So
don't laugh. Come on.
I am trying my best here.
Alright. So let's
grab the internal IP system.
Two.
My wife always asked me why people watch
it when I stream. And when I do
moments like this, wonder why too.
It's because it's
it brings us all closer together. We realize
we're not the only ones who do this
sort of thing, know?
Okay. So I
we're NGINX. We're not using elastic IP actually.
We're just gonna hard code this h a
proxy to be its own IP address and
other h a proxy to be its own
IP address. And I'm gonna copy this and
then we'll do that on h a proxy
too. But I should be able to save
that to a restart
issue proxy.
Bastard.
What did I get wrong?
Must just be
oh, that looks good.
Okay. Let's so we can do a h
a proxy check
also coming from the docs that I shared
a moment ago. It tells you to do
that first anyway.
I'm just a cowboy.
So
front end tries to use incompatible TCP back
end at your next pull as its default
back end. See mode.
Modes did did mode TCP for the front
end?
That is not listed.
Let's example
we do have some defaults.
There
we go. Okay.
So the mode should be HTTP,
not TCP.
Perfect.
Alright.
Now
in theory,
I'm gonna open a new in fact, let's
open a code window. I wanna paste that
before I lose it. Right? And then we
wanna SSH onto a t proxy too and
then we can confirm the setup actually works.
So
last time I'm doing that. Okay.
So we can test the 80 proxy one
first. Right?
Should be able to hit this on port
80.
We've got no back ends. That's that's kinda
working. Right? I'm gonna I'll I'll take that
for now.
Okay.
Let's work out our back end situational.
What did I get wrong?
So we should let's cat that fail actually.
Ping +1
0120129.
Curl.
They may just not be healthy yet. So
issue proxy will be testing them and waiting
for them to pass a certain number of
times before it delivers them as healthy traffic.
Right? That's how it works. Yeah.
That's the check part of the Yeah. So
let's see.
Nothing configured. So it's probably gonna be up
at thirty seconds if I remember correctly. But
that's me come back a while. So
let's get the other one up and running.
And we're just gonna drop in.
Like that. I think it's a good thing
I did that.
And that's gonna be the exact same except
we're gonna bind on its own IP address.
Restart.
Itchy.
Oh,
the mode. Mode. Yeah.
Thanks, Dan. I'm glad you're paying attention.
Okay. Let's run the config check. I'm not
sure what it's gonna be more about.
Okay.
Just needed a second.
Cool.
So let's see if we've got a healthy
itchy proxy one.
Nice. Okay.
I can stop panicking there. So we have
an artificially
where did Tom go?
Oh. Tom. He's coming back. I'm here.
Sorry.
Okay. So we have a artificially scaled engine
x configuration right now. Assume this is your
application.
You got two eighty proxies running, delivering traffic
to that and that's great. But right now,
we have a situation and if we point
our
elastic IP address to one of our h
a proxies and it goes down, we have
no high availability.
So
based on what
Dan said, step one is gonna be to
install birds, which we should
have.
And we have version one sixty.
So what do we do next?
So we need to ask Equinix Mettle for
an EIP.
Actually, there's a number of steps that we
need to do. Sorry. The first thing that
we need to do is to enable BGP
on our two HAProxy nodes.
So, we'll need to edit both of those
machines.
Turn on I think it is manage
I p v four
and enable BGP.
What's the default route thing you need, Jiggy?
I don't think we need to worry about
that.
Alright. I can do Let's
do it. So
what's actually happening here is the we're basically
enabling the
there's this internal things happening where we're basically
telling the top of rack switches that these
physical service sit underneath,
that they will be allowed to advertise routes
to those top rack switches.
Okay.
We have a couple of questions.
So will we tackle them just now?
We can do. Feeling brave? Alright. So we
got well, got a hey first from fusion
one. Hello. You're watching on Twitch. Nice.
Tom O'Connor asked, does anyone still use Quagga?
What's Quagga?
So somebody brought Quagga earlier
in a different conversation that I was having
today.
I don't spend all day talking about BGP,
but it seems like a very strange day
for BGP questions.
I have not heard of Quagga before until
earlier, and I didn't research it. But apparently,
I think it's just another BGP
server. So BGP is a a a a
software suite of of
routing
software.
Looks like it runs in a bunch of
different places. For whatever reason though,
most places at the moment seem to have,
as as I mentioned earlier, have have kind
of migrated towards bird. I I don't know
why.
I think it just has slowly become
the more popular of the the routing software
stacks that people people run these days.
Alright. Nice.
One funkman.
Does
h a proxy check also look for a
specific status code?
So off the top of my head, I
think h a proxy
will expect a 200 or two x x
code and or remove it from the pool
if there's any five hundreds, four hundreds are
obviously client side. So it does by default
as far as I am concerned. If anyone
wants to correct me, feel free. But yes,
we'll remove them if they are unhealthy or
unreachable too.
Oh and a colleague Ed says thanks for
the livestream.
Thank you for watching.
Hey Ed.
Hi Ed. So
we have in fact, what we request in
your elastic IP?
Yes, Dave. Okay. Thanks. Yes. So
let's just grab one. We don't need any
more.
BGP demo, that'll help me remember to delete
it later.
And that should pretty much be instant.
There we go. Exactly.
So I'm gonna copy this.
So we've enabled BGP on both of our
machines, which means that the
top of Rack switch knows to expect us
to announce something.
So we want to hear now tell Bird
that it can announce the IP. Is that
right? So the first thing that we want
to do
is to add
that IP address, that EIP,
to our loopback interface.
That IP address needs to exist on something
on the physical host itself.
Otherwise, when traffic is set there from the
outside world,
we'll just ignore it.
So
what we will need to do
is typically we will create a sub interface
on the loop back.
Alright.
Let's see if I remember this stuff. Networking.
So Network and then interfaces.
Yep.
And
where is low?
So we will need to create a new
interface.
I face low colon zero
INEX static
because it's an address replying to it. Yep.
That's all I remember.
And then, yeah, it's net masks all the
20 fives. Oh, yeah. Five fives.
Zero? No. Yeah.
Because it's Yep. 32. Okay. Yep. That's it.
Right? That is it. Yep.
So once we
This is where we laugh when I get
kicked off the machine. We can do an
if up actually, which will only affect the
that interface.
Why has that not worked?
Can you bring up the interfaces file?
Oh, this is a bit to 20, actually.
So It should still work, I think.
We started it.
Did it?
Oh, it did.
That's strange.
Yeah. It's because this is I don't think
the f up stuff particularly works for the
modern more advantage. You're supposed to do IP
as a dev or something and then up.
See
if I can remember.
Link,
low, zero,
up.
I think if you still need to edit
the interfaces, folks, I think we missed a
line off,
which was the auto
yep. Need to have the auto line above
the
low zero.
Alright. Yep.
Is that why they have upfield then? I
think so. Yeah.
And I'm a good chat there about it
being deprecated.
Okay.
So
Equinix Messle have also made our lives a
lot easier.
I think we will need to add some
additional tooling for this to actually work. So
we'll need
Python three dot six,
git, and Python three dash pip adding
to
to our systems.
K.
We don't want Python two. Why is that
even still the default? Oh, we do have
Python three. It just wasn't available under. Right.
K. Which means we probably have pep three.
No.
Alright. So let the app install
Python three.
And getters. Okay.
Get should be no. Get won't be on
the machine.
We'll see.
For minimized
or compressed Ubuntu,
the normal one that we that we get.
That was the that was last Metal Monday's
issue was git was not on there. Was
git wasn't on there? Yep. Not in the
not
in the compressed version
or the minimized version.
Alright.
That's noted for future. Next time I'm fighting
with that, need to install git. So are
you gonna tell me to get clone the
network helpers?
Yes. So with all of those bits in
place, we can grab the network helpers package,
which
will automate a lot of well, it'll automate
the entire bird config, actually.
Sounds good to me. Yeah. Staying stay me
up.
Okay.
So
what do we have here? We got some
Python scripts. We've got a RIPNI, a Dockerfile.
So the first thing that we will need
to do is install
a couple of things. So a pip three
install of
JMS path.
Mhmm.
Done.
And then pip three install minus e current
directory.
Oh, alright. Okay.
Install dashi dot.
That will get all of the dependencies that
we actually need.
The the final step now is that we
can use that Python script to actually configure
the config for us. We can do it
so it prints straight to standard out. So
we can actually see what it's gonna do.
So if you do minus r and then
bird
Mhmm. This should generate our entire bird config
for us. So
if we look here,
we can see
a number of things. One,
the router ID, that's ourselves. That's this particular
machine is going to be a BGP router.
The
interface local host is where
the
bird daemon will look for the EIP
to tell the rest of the other servers
the other machines about.
If we scroll a little bit further down,
we will find
our neighbors.
Our neighbors
are
basically the top of rack switches.
So when we enabled BGP,
that set up that kind of configuration that
allowed this particular machine to speak to those
neighbors to tell them that they have an
EIP that they're advertising.
So the Python script has gotten all of
that information for us.
We can now tell these two neighbors that
we have the EIP.
Is that getting that from the metadata?
I believe so because I don't think this
is using the wow. Yes. It is, I
guess. It's a peer IPs. Peer IPs. Yep.
Nice.
Very nice. I didn't actually know that was
how it was doing it. I I just
took a guess because I learn learn something
new every day.
Alright. So I guess we wanna run that
configure again and we wanna
store that somewhere?
We can
key that straight into at cdbirdbird.com.
Bird or board? Bird.
Just my typing. No. It's not you.
Done.
Nope. Bird, bird, bird is the word, McKay.
Now,
if we do a system CTL restart bird,
And
there's a couple commands we can do if
we do a bird c,
and we do show
protocols.
Oh, sorry. Sorry.
All space all
space neighbor
underscore
v four underscore one.
Cat hair. Rolls rolls US.
US. Must be right. Yeah. U US. Yeah.
Underscore V V 4 Underscore 1.
So here we go. We have got if
you look I'm trying to highlight this with
my mouse.
BGP state is established,
So we are speaking to
other
peer neighbors,
and we are advertising our routes to them.
Very cool.
So
we are now letting other devices know that
we have IP addresses
and that if they when they have traffic
for them, to send them to this machine.
Now this can take a few minutes to
fully propagate
for the first time.
Okay.
So do we need to do this again
on the other machine? So, yeah, we need
to do all of that on the other
machine.
Godspeed.
Network
helpers.
Install get Python three.
Was there another one? I don't think so.
We'll need to edit the local host config
as well. You should be able to grab
that config from the other one the other
one.
I'm
feeling brave.
So enter faces. Wow.
Auto load zero. I face load zero.
Next static
address.
I'll need to copy that from somewhere and
then there was a net mass. Yep.
And it's the same IP.
All good? Yep. That looks good.
If up, might work.
Oh, maybe it just fails the first time.
There we go. Okay. Let's ignore that. So,
now that I've copied these, oh, there was
a pep three install
g m e's path.
Don't know what that is, but we'll have
it. And Oh, yeah. Alright. Now I can
do the git clone.
And then there was
CD network helpers.
PIP three dash install dash e dot? Yep.
Scrub all of the
dependencies.
I have some three config bird dash r.
Oops. No. It's minus r bird.
Bastard.
So close though.
Etcetera.
Birdbird.conf.
Alright.
Restart.
So
does that mean that we have two copies
of bird advertising the same IP address? We
do. Yes. Is that good? Is that bad?
So is that normal?
It's
so I I thought
obviously, playing with Bird the first time when
I kinda first started here,
I thought it sounded kind of quite a
crazy thing to do.
Multiple hosts will advertise in the same IP
address.
On a network, typically, if you if you
were to try and do that by giving
multiple devices the same IP address, you end
up in an IP address conflict.
But this is not kind of working in
the same way. So for a start, the
the EIP address is bounced to local host.
So it's not proliferating itself on the network.
What's actually happening here is that Bird is
essentially
doing a TCP connection to those top of
rack switches, those networking devices, and advertising routes
to say,
if traffic comes to this top of rack
switch with the EIP,
send it to
send it to me. Now multiple hosts can
say that, and the top of rack switch
will then do load balancing for us and
for us. So if, for instance, one of
these machines goes down and stops having that
communication to the top of rack switches,
that route will be removed,
At which point, EIP traffic will only go
to the remaining nodes
that are advertising that address.
Okay. Nice. Nice. So we're getting load balancing
on the EIP,
which is all the governance high availability and
we've got our engine axes who are completely
oblivious to all of that who are just
responding to traffic. Yep. Awesome.
Alright.
We got another comment from Tom O'Connor
who just.
Okay. Cool. Is your proxy allows you to
configure what status code to expect with http
check expect? So you so you could say
200 frames, 300 the same, etcetera. Nice.
If you know what the defaults are, feel
free to drop that in the comments too
so we can share it.
How then do we confirm
this is working? Should I be able to
browse to my EIP now?
Hopefully.
Oh.
That's strange.
No. Is that just a time thing? Does
that mean we're just a little quick?
I shouldn't think so. No.
So I broke it.
Why is that not working?
What was that proxy command again? Can I
run that one on the other Yep?
But if one of them's advertising then,
the command is show space protocols
space all
neighbor.
What neighbor?
IP four one. Yeah. With underscores.
So it's under
neighbor underscore
I v four.
Yep. There's an underscore between neighbor and
delete the extra.
Underscore v four underscore one. There we go.
So close. Okay. So
it's established.
It's working.
So what we can also do is if
we go back to the
Equinix metal portal,
we should be able to see from the
machines
okay.
It's down. Oh,
why are you down
when you say you're up? Can I hit
update?
Yep.
Learned routes. Okay. So they
the routes have been learned.
So we have update, which is told the
router, the switch, the ASN, or whatever we
call that that
to recheck
for those published
routes, which we now got.
I still can't hit that, but I'll ignore
that for now.
If we the AJ proxy is is all
up and running as expected. So if we
Well, we can confirm that's still working or
just hidden their IPs.
This looks okay to me. Yep. Yep.
So we should oh, hang on a second.
Your HAProxy is bound to the it's bound
to the IP address.
Uh-huh. Bind it to 0000
and it will bind to
all and sundry.
We knew that. We were just testing you
by the way.
Tom and I, Jeremy, talked some of that
upfront. We're like And passed. Pop quiz. I'm
hoping this fixes everything.
Okay. Good catch, by the way. I would
have spent at least three weeks looking at
that. So
Delete to there.
Zero zero zero.
Certainly fingers across right now.
Alright. So Please work. Please work. We'll that
in a minute. We'll we'll just tackle another
comment before we we test it. So Tom
got back to this and says, the default
with option is to be checked as anything
two x x or three x x. It's
fine.
Expect this handy if you actually want to
do if you want to handle, I guess
five x x errors
back up to something else. Nice. Thank you,
Tom for that. Very useful. Alright
then. Moment of truth.
I'm out. You did it.
Very nice. That is very
cool.
Now,
I wanna
confirm some
assumptions we made there about the load balancing
on the bird side. So
is there anything like I'm sorry. I'm gonna
go to my machine and curl. Will be
anything in the headers that tells me which
machine satisfied that?
We don't know. Let's find out.
Server engine x.
Oh, there's two h t t p's there.
Was hoping it would reveal. Oh, well, maybe
the e tag will reveal. No. That's gonna
be on the document that delivers. Strats. Yeah.
I was thinking of I didn't mention, but
for demo purposes on each of those, the
the the default page for NGINX just numbering
just numbering them off.
You know what? Yeah.
What I wanted to see was, like, if
we shut down one of the h two
proxies just
just to see
it still working. That is going to the
other one. But I guess we can just
shut one down anyway. Right? So
I mean we should still at least see
errors in
no we wouldn't wouldn't we? Well we're taking
down h a proxy.
Well, yeah. So now BGP's advertising on address
that's not gonna be resolved?
Yeah. So in theory, we may load balance
now to a a dead h a proxy
instance because the server is still up.
Okay.
Is there a
what would be the route then for me
to make sure that
bird as an advertising address of HAProxy. Well,
I guess if h a proxy wasn't wasn't
resolving to that address, the machine would be
offline, really. So I I yeah. So, I
mean, so logic
logic doesn't exist in this case. You would
need to implement something or other which basically
stops this machine routing traffic unless it actually
has a service running.
So if engine x goes down, then in
theory, Bird should stop.
I'm happy with that assumption too.
Nice. Well At the moment, yeah, there there
are two different services that aren't intertwined
as such. So
all Bird cares about is basically saying to
the outside world, I have this IP address.
We need to then combine logic which says,
there's no point having this IP address if
the service is down. Yeah. I mean, we
could you could probably put that logic together
in system d by having, you know, 80
proxies or dependency on bird. And then if
one goes down, it's gonna, you know, restart
them and stuff like that. Yeah, there was
around that. I was just curious.
Throwing
random stuff as we were about to finish.
That would be neat.
Alright. Well, what we'll do is we'll give
if anyone has any questions, feel free to
drop them in the comments. We'll tackle them
and we'll wait a minute.
Tom's gonna tell us a joke just now.
Okay. You weren't paying attention, Tom. I am
telling a joke.
You all ready?
I'm ready. Do you have a joke? You
have a joke? It's it's one I got
for my daughter this morning. What did the
cow say when or what did the cat
say when it fell out of the out
of the tree?
Meow.
Oh, sorry, guys.
As as we were wrapping, Makih, I thought
it may be good to go back to
document the documentation
also. And if there was that architecture diagram,
I love pictures
that we could
look at for just a moment, unless you
wanted to draw one freehand.
But
Whiteboard it.
Alright.
And
Oh.
Uh-oh. I'm
not doing that. So that's not happening.
I was really excited.
But just the just for a quick visual
representation of what was
of the digital sand castle that was built.
Is this what you want? Yeah.
Do you wanna walk through it?
And so we can break any one of
those
break any one of those pieces, and it
will still end up with a web server?
The difference between
what we're looking at here is that our
our our system that we built today is
actually active active.
So
the EIP
will send traffic to both load balancers.
Ah, okay. It doesn't there's no kind of
no checking going on regardless of the
the the state of the load balancer. Say
the machine is different than the state of
the load balancer. So if the machine exists
and the machine is up and running, then
the the path is active to that load
balancer machine.
Right. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. And I get that.
Yeah. Because we're we're taking advantage of this.
I
can't remember what you call it. Is it
switcher or richer that does the BGP advertising?
It's a richer. Right? Rooster. Yep. This is
layer layer three. Yep. So that richer for
us is is load balancing for us. But
if we did want an active passive approach,
we would just be running bird on one
machine or leveraging other tools that was a
bit more sophisticated and could move Yeah. Like,
is that where keep a live d would
would come in? Would that be able to
do something like that? Yep. Another alternative
is
you can
there there is capability
inside the Equinix Metal API
to say,
without using BGP,
to speak to Equinix Metal API to do,
like, a direct association of an EIP to
a single machine.
So
not using BGP,
that will basically program the top rack switches
with a static route,
which says traffic for that AIP goes to
this one machine.
And that's that's through an API call.
Ah, nice. Okay. I like that too. Something
for us to play with another day for
sure. Yep. It's a little bit slower
is is the main thing to and the
main thing to be aware of.
Alright.
I I don't think we're gonna get any
more questions. If they do come in, they
come in after the buzzer, which means we
will follow-up in the comment section later.
Anything from anyone else before we we wrap
up?
I have a joke. What
is a bird's favorite game?
Beakaboo.
I don't know. Hey,
MacKay. Do you wanna throw up your
your promo code so that people can try
this stuff out for free on Equinix Medal?
Boom.
There we go. Yeah.
That is more than enough to test out
and play with.
Yeah. It was really great about that $50.
It's like, I've been trying to work out
where the sweet spot is and like you
can get a hundred hours of our small
instances which is ridiculous value.
But you can also spend that pretty quick.
You can spend it in like less than
twenty hours with the top of the lane
machines. You know, pick your poison wisely people.
Alright. Well, thank you very much for joining
us, Dan. It was great having you on
metal Mondays. We really enjoyed that and your
insights were fantastic as always.
Best dungeon master.
Absolutely.
Do you
and next week, we won't have metal Mondays,
but, Makay, you have something else
exciting for next Monday. Right?
Next Monday,
the KubeCon wrap up show? Yes. Yeah.
Obviously, the yeah. This week is KubeCon North
America virtual.
I think it is Tuesday through Friday.
I will be sitting up ex stupidly late
watching every single talk that I can so
that we can talk about it next week
and I have a host of guests joining
us as well from the Kubernetes So
we will be taking a look at the
news,
the new features and all the awesome talks
that we've seen and giving you the load
out of what we liked. It'll be awesome.
Very cool.
You can also walk your virtual body by
our digital booth.
Yeah.
I think every one of us will be
there at some point throughout the week. So
come say hi.
Alright. Sweet. Well, thank you all of you
for your time. Have a great day and
I will speak to you all very very
soon. Goodbye and a happy Monday.